Can you make a difference here and now It's impossible if
you throw away science
That's all
I'm afraid No matter how much normalization is a fantasy It
's the foundation of chemistry There's absolutely no yura
[music]
[applause]
ani
how much time
The body of the face floated up, but the body of the face protects the sky 0kurokuro
From the stone age of mankind to the modern age
2 million yen
I will run up there at once
I will return the world to
you The principle of changing clothes and resurrection is also irreversible  Find it out
ah ah ah
ani
For Sted Messe,
we'll take back civilization,
then I
promised you ah ah
ran
You might really be able to create modern civilization from scratch Turn
me over to space and Doraemon  I'm a boy who loves technology
, so I'll use the power of science to help all human fibers.
goo
ni
try sted messe
mcrae we take back civilization